honestly I think everyone is different
and unique and that's a good thing
it's not bad it's kind of the best thing
in the world you don't want to be like
everyone else because that's when you
grow when you when you leave your
comfort zone and try something new but
the less I care about other people's
opinions the better I feel about myself
and the more I do things that make me
happy need motivation watch a top ten of
belief nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew on today's lessons from
a woman who was born in Bulgaria and at
age two moved to my hometown of Toronto
Canada to becoming an actress best known
for her work in the Vampire Diaries
she's Nina Dobrev and here is my take on
her top ten roses success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite work
hard my parents couldn't afford to put
me in a lot of like dance classes and
things like that but we would throw me
into like the community ones and it
created this the free ones
yeah the free ones yeah and then
eventually when I started acting or it
it started with modeling and then I turn
into acting they didn't approve of it
they didn't have the money to support it
so with my jobs I would pay for the
headshots and I would go take classes
and take four different buses and a
subway to get downtown from the suburbs
in Toronto where I loved to get to the
class I get a hat I wanted it and if
like if I didn't actually put in the
work for it I wouldn't have gotten to
where I am and and I really had to be
from within rule number two
embrace your uniqueness honestly I think
everyone is different and unique and
that's a good thing it's not bad it's
kind of the best thing in the world you
don't want to be like everyone else
growing up in high school and just doing
your high just your whole life really
either you have been taught to feel like
or you want to be like everyone else
because I'm conceptually you you'll be
included and you'll be like the crowd
but when you think about it when you
look at people like Lady gaga who is so
crazy and so different and so unique and
her whole message is about you know
being yourself and being okay with it
and she the reason she is so successful
and so is because she's talented because
she's different if she was just like
Britney Spears or if she was just like
you know mean nina dobrev then there
would be two of us so there'd be nothing
special about that so I think what's
what's special is the fact that you're
different and is the fact that you're
unique and that you can bring something
to the table so if anything embrace that
that that uniqueness and that
that's thing that you have that no one
else does and expand upon it and make it
better and tell everyone about it and be
confident in it because if you're
confident and happy and smiling you will
attract confidence happiness and
laughter rule number three don't put all
your eggs in one basket you know you
were in the perks of being a wallflower
and of course this big budget monster do
you find that it's good to kind of go
back and forth between Indies and
big-budget and sort of find your way
oh no absolutely not I'm definitely
doing action movies from now on no I'm
joking
um yeah I think it definitely is a
balance you have to balance yeah there's
so many things I want to do and I love
being a part of parks it's such a
beautiful story and such a important
movie and it was it's near and dear to
my heart and this movie was a lot of fun
to do and in a very different kind of
way but yeah I I definitely want to go
kind of you don't put all your eggs in
one basket you kind of go back and forth
rule number four be your own advocate I
my closest friends and my mom and my
closest confidants always say that I'm
very determined and very stubborn and
pushy and then it could be a good thing
and it can be a bad thing like it
definitely gets me what I want what I
want to need and I'm very vocal about
things in blunt but but you sort of have
to be that way you have to be your own
your own agent your own advocate in your
own you have to go for what you want to
me rule number five stick to it it's a
lot of hard work it looks glamorous but
it's it's a lot of studying and a lot of
auditioning and a lot of rejection you
gotta have really thick skin to to
prevail but if your heart isn't it you
have to stick to it yeah and good things
will come
rule number six do something differently
I want to play roles that are different
than the ones I've played in the past
that will challenge me that will make me
scared hopefully take me out of my
comfort zone because that's when you
grow when you when you leave your
comfort zone and try something new how
did you come about finding this role of
Becky did you audition
or is that something that they thought
you'd be perfect for the role and they
called you up gosh that would have been
fun I wish I wish they'd offered me the
role no I I think initially they wanted
they wanted to see me for the Sereno
role which is the more like ass-kicking
the the female lead in the film and I
when I was reading it I just laughed so
hard at all of Becky's lines and I
thought it would be such a much bigger
departure for me it might at this point
in my career to to play a role that was
different than anything I've ever done
before and so I embraced the glasses I
went into the audition did something
right because now I'm here and that's me
right there on the poster rule number
seven don't care what others think every
single person when they're in their
teens in their early 20s they they care
so much about other people and how
they're perceived and what impression
they make and I wanted to be perfect I
wanted to be good at everything and be a
good student and be prettier and
skinnier and successful and all these
things and I cared about what people
said about me how they felt about me and
as I get older I just realize that that
is that one other people won't make me
happy it has to be from within me and I
need to keep doing whatever makes me
happy and whoever responds to that great
whoever doesn't respond to that it's
fine - mm-hmm
but the less I care about other people's
opinions the better I feel about myself
and the more I do things that make me
happy rule number eight care about
others I remember one day I was having a
terrible day at school
nothing could go right and whether it
was about me or my friends or something
at home it just I just wasn't happy that
day and someone came up to me or not
even came up to me just walked by me and
said something like I like your hair or
you look rested today or whatever it was
seemingly insignificant but it had the
most significance because it completely
turned my day around
and that's the kind of thing that that I
felt and recognized and told myself I
made a mental note I was like you know
I'm gonna do that from now on whenever
I'm gonna make it a point at least once
a day if not more
hopefully tens 20 times a day to walk up
to someone or walk by someone and point
out something about them that I like or
say something nice and positive because
it could change their day it could make
them feel good about themselves and it
will actually because I know that it
felt made me feel that way
rule number nine work in a great
environment a great thing about this
film and my experience with DJ the
director and then is that they created
an environment that was very freeing and
open and inclusive so no idea was a bad
idea I was able to kind of do and say
whatever I wanted ad-lib improv I felt
comfortable I could take risks and when
you when you were allowed that as an
actor when you have that freedom it it
allows for you to also kind of play
around and then magical things happen
when you play and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips for you is be a thrill seeker
jumped into the new year 2016 ready for
me alright yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I used to be scared and either in the
facts sharks keep the ocean healthy and
they aren't really interested in us it's
our interest in their fins that's scary
millions of sharks end up in the global
fin trade every year and many grow
slowly which means they face a high risk
of extinction
please help and join me and Oceana and
the campaign to stop the trade of shark
fins and help save sharks
now I've got two really special Nina
bonus clips for you around being hungry
for success and how she evolves but
before that my question today is I want
to know what is your favorite Nina
character of all time what role did you
love the most that she has played leave
it down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
my mom my brother and I applied I mean
my mom applied for my brother shirt for
a visa to visit our family in Michigan I
believe and so we flew to Michigan for a
week it was supposed to be and then from
there they drove us to the Canadian
American border where my mom with one
suitcase a six year old and a two year
old and her arms walked across the
Niagara Falls border shut up and that's
how we got in walked across walked
across like a bridge that you walk
across from Canada to America was it
like a customs checkpoint or was it more
of like that Ross I think not the
impression was a sneak across oh really
yeah I don't know yeah I'm pretty sure
it was Wow but I don't quote quote me on
you have to ask your mom yeah a little I
know I personally don't remember any of
these things Wow it's amazing so did you
guys have did your parents have savings
or do they have a place to stay when
they got to Canada or was it more I
think there was we shared an apartment
with another family or two other things
well barring family our yeah and until
we figured out what we were gonna do I
mean all I did was just say Gaga and do
do it right I wasn't doing much but I so
I hit take credit but my dad worked as a
pizza delivery guy he worked at the gas
station as a pumper they took odd jobs
like that at the beginning they'd have
nothing they didn't speak the language
and then as time went on they started to
learn and started to get better jobs and
my mom was a painter but my dad I
learned to become a computer specialist
Wow and yeah it's crazy it's crazy to
think that they that's they had to go
through so much to get here to give us
the life that we had yeah and as a child
I remember feeling ungrateful to really
her that yeah I mean you do cuz I didn't
know mm-hmm so we were even know what
they had to give up or what that is
sacrificed to get me to where I was and
and I went to a good public school and
all my friends had all these things they
have like beautiful new clothes and he's
hot like big houses and I always felt
like and we also weren't allowed to
speak English at home we had to speak
Bulgarian at home in English at school
so that we could preserve our mother
tongue and I hated that I thought that
was so annoying and I'm rebelling
against it and it was a writing rhyme
why can't I have new clothes like my
friends do why do we have to go to
Salvation Army to buy our clothes or
just I didn't I hated it
if I didn't have that experience of
wanting things and not having things
that I wanted it made me work extra hard
to achieve and get what I wanted to have
in my life yeah you know and I feel like
a lot of people don't understand that
now we have so many things to at our
disposal running water is so easy to
just get then we take that for granted
and like I when I went to Kenya to build
a school for both school and well and
that's what that's that's when I learned
that was it I was like wow we can't play
that we have such so many things around
us and so many people don't and so many
people can get in their cars and go from
A to B and we have so much and
everyone's so lucky and that's a great
thing but it's also sometimes can be a
disadvantage for some people in my
opinion of course
yeah the struggle is what makes you
thrive for success my most proud moment
is is realizing and noticing just the
paradigm change and how how much
everybody's evolving and seeing not only
my career and how much it changes but my
best friends my everyone around me
seeing everyone grow and kind of get to
that next level
in their own careers it's just amazing
to look around and see everyone blossom
and bloom into these beautiful flowers
and now we're in like a field of color
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon they
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]